GOOD MORNING THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
FRIDAY MAY TWENTY FIFTH IS
HEREBY COLD ORDER. PLEASE REVISE
AND AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS GREEN BAY.
HAS ALSO BEEN TELEVISED.
ALLEN BETTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FULLY. HERE
I HAVE CARILLO.
CERVANTES
HERE FRIEDMAN HERE GALLAGHER
GRAYSON PARISH MAYES
PRESIDENT AS AREA PRESENT SALAS
PRESENCE WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. OF.
WE HAVE A CONGENITAL AS CONSENT
AGENDA WE ARE ADDING.
AB A TWIN AND WIDER TO THE BILL
REFERRAL S..
I.
AND THERE'S A REQUEST TIGHTLY TO
PULL IN A MINUTE SEVEN
CREATES A BUILDUP.
I HAVE SENT FROM THE CONSENT FOR
SEPARATE VOTE.
IS OUR MOTION ON THE
BALANCE THE CONSENT AGENDA.
CONSENT GENNARO.
A BILL BY SCOTT WHINER
CONCERNING.
CANIBUS.
RISK AND REVIEWED WITH.
STAFF IN BOTH HOUSES.
THIS IS A MEASURE DEALING WITH
CANIBUS.
AND I TAXES AS THEY AFFECT
ACCESS TO.
AFFORDABLE MEDICAL MARIJUANA.
WHICH IS A PART OF THE
UNDERLYING.
PREMISE AND PROMISE
OF AB TWENTY FIVE TO FIFTEEN OF
NINETEEN. NINETY SIX.
.
AND I I WOULD MAKE A PERSONAL
APPEAL I ACTUALLY FEEL.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WILL BE
BENEFITED BY HAVING.
BILL WITH THESE AMENDMENTS IN
PRINT.
WHICH I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
PUBLIC CONVERSATION WE ARE
SYSTEM.
WITH THAT.
SO WE HAVE A.
MISTER NAZARIAN MOVED ON THE
BALANCE OF CONSENT AGENDA AND A
SECOND.
THIS CARILLO WAS SECOND.
MANAGE SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
KOREA.
AYE CARILLO AYE CERVANTES AYE
CERVANTES AYE FRIEDMAN AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE GALLAGHER GRACIA.
GRAYSON AYE MAYES SITE MAYES I
KNOW THE AREA.
THOSE ARE AND I SOLIS AYE SALAS
AYE WALDRON.
RUSSIAN.
OKAY THE. OLDER. AS AMENDED HIS
PANTS.
IS OUR MOTION OUT OF SEVEN.
YOU'RE SICK BECAUSE REQUEST FOR
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE GIVE
GIPSON.
SO MOVED. SECOND OF MOVE BY
MISTRESS VERY SECULAR BY MS
FRIEDMAN.
BOB BAER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLING BY COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM THREE OUT AYE CARILLO
AYE CERVANTES.
CERVANTES NOT VOTING FRIEDMAN
AYE FRIEDMAN AYE GALLAGHER.
GRAYSON AYE GRAYSON AYE MAYES
SO.
MAYES KNOWN AS AREA. THIS AREA
AND I SOLIS.
I.
SALAS I'D. MUCH. MOTIONS PASSED.